as you sit here 15 years after you've
started this journey talk a little bit
about the growth of DOM and this path
that you've taken and how I know you're
proud of it I've become a man on the
saga you know I was young and when I
started it and and now I'm a family man
and now I you know I've got when I first
came on it was just just had to deal
with the responsibility of portraying
the character and now I have greater
responsibilities protecting us
protecting mythology for for a global
audience yeah I hope you know I become
more precious about things more precious
about my relationships and people more
protective of them
and I want to do significant work you
know I I don't need to just work so if I
I'm going to do it as you know person
and I go a hundred and ten thousand
seven certain emotional maturity
throughout the picture time that's
allotted to in this story time that's
allotted to just relationships Dharma
Metis relationship
uncovering the past you know I think
there I think there are more metaphors
in this fast and furious and any of the
other capacity reasons
it feels mature in a certain way and I
think it saw a full experience it's so
rare to have a complete full experience
when you see movies nowadays and it's
one of the cool things about this film
that you nothing's left on the table you
get it all yeah you get everything and
you get it with with guys that you've
known and broke the audience has grown
up with their characters the audience
has grown up with their characters you
were there Monday night when I went to
present the first screening doc in
California and you were there when I got
emotionally choked up just looking at
Paul and you were there when the fans in
the audience yelled out we're with you
we got you we love you and you got
family here then what's better than them
you can get all the accolades and
in the world but what's better than
having your audience feel as though they
are your family and they are your
support system and it's profound and
that they're going through what you're
going through they're going through it
with you and that's what they're saying
and that's what they've been saying and
that was part of the encouraging kind of
backup that the fans have been giving
throughout this whole process when we
were coming up when we were lost when we
were dumped on the way we were shocked
by the tragedy it was the audience
saying we'll ride with you guys ride
this out and would be there with you and
that touches me and that's an app that
made us all go into it with that much
more conviction it's incredibly it's not
advanced people say it's it's not a
movie I think it's hard to say it's a
movie it's hard you can't just say you
know it's so funny when people try to
describe how they feel about the movie
don't go they feel weird saying it's a
good movie or it's a great movie because
even that feels like if selling
insurance and they'd be like no I don't
want to just say it's a good I don't
want to could take it like I normally
critique movies
I wouldn't put this in a different
category I want to say that this is our
life right the new cast members that
you've brought in this time I mean
they're all incredible they're all
incredible and they all came to really
really work and really really play and
that that's you know as a producer you
could only hope for that but as somebody
that suffers from that kind of tragic
loss of a dear friend and their brother
you don't realize how much you need it
back you don't realize how much you
needed everybody to come in and
be there as your support group you know
I've never needed a support group of my
love I never even thought that you know
I'm i've always been this Jane
I've always been there I don't know how
else to put it
and after this thing happened you
quickly realize you need you need your
support team like anybody else in your
human you know it's it's always fun when
we see it in the movie but I gotta tell
you for the years leading up to it it's
a harrowing experience because you are
thinking to yourself how in the world am
I going to top the last movie or how am
I gonna talk to stumps in the sequences
and always happens luckily we had a team
that was so well-oiled that we were able
to reach for something pretty crazy
there was a theme we were playing with
the idea of flying cars there's actually
semen never got shot where Jack is
throwing his cars at the wall and brian
says hey man cars on fly which was going
to dovetail and set up all the flying
cars it was really so it's uh it's a
testament to a great team it's a
testament to a great studio studio
that's been so supportive and willing to
back up these insane ideas
you